what's up party people welcome to honest
trailer commentaries the show where we
talk about our show that is talking
about other movies I'm Joe star that's
Dan Merle moving the headphones off the
table yeah if you like hello today we're
talking about the honest trailer for a
star is born so if you haven't watched
that yet hit pause here go back watch
the honest trailer first star is born
and then come back to see our insightful
commentary about the movie and the
honest trailer maybe some deleted scenes
and jokes or just watch this I don't
know a lot of guys do that yeah we have
some news we do you'll notice that I was
the one who greeted you as party people
today that is because you drop it Dan
all I get to do it yeah you get to it's
happy news it's good news no terrible
that's not the news this is good news
we'll try to bring in some other folks
cuz we have some other folks that are
helping us over the next several weeks
six weeks but Spencer J Gilbert is on
paternity leave because there's another
little gilbert running around our world
so first of all congrats congratulations
by the Gilbert family
we will miss Spencer here we'll do our
best not to leave him nothing to come
back to yep no promises yeah it's
probably already on fire I don't know
but yeah so congrats to Spencer he won't
be here for the next several weeks but
he's raising a baby he will still will
still be here yeah and I baby the two of
us and then whomever else we can pull
into the writers room can maybe equal
one Spencer I hope so I hope so too
I'm already feeling the pressure a
little bit well Joe it's only we're all
we're only doing the biggest movies that
came out at the end of last year so
perfect timing yeah I'm so glad he chose
now to have a kid and better is like you
know what good job cuz I would skip some
of these movies too sure I were him yeah
I got a baby no what can I do
congratulations Spencer congratulations
buddy show him some love on Twitter yeah
I don't really know what else to say
other than that
stars board oh yeah we got a video to do
let's talk stars born yeah I know I
thought I liked I liked this movie yeah
you know what I like
I very much like the first half of this
I loved the first movie and the second
half is a little weird yeah I will say
this I love the the the first half of
this movie builds up so much goodwill
for me that I did not hate the second
half I just followed through it
perplexed and hoping it would write
itself this movie it's it's it's my
version of the jump to shark because so
now I'm gonna say the movie peed its
pants because for me is the dividing
point Rubicon when Bradley Cooper pees
his pants that's what I fall off a
little bit because I just don't quite
get the motivations and his motivation
and why it all goes a little fudge fuzzy
for me everything starts to get a little
bit before the pants painting yeah it's
great everything before the pee pants
yes everything before there so there's
still got all my pee pants yeah sorry
Ricky Bobby yeah this let's say some
nice things first and then we can really
dive in I think I really do think
Bradley Cooper's an excellent director
I loved especially first half the movie
that the two of them sitting in the
parking lot just the weird naturalistic
style and the the flow of conversation I
think is absolutely fantastic talented
director yeah great music mm-hmm
I liked Lady gaga she was not my Oscar
winner but I thought she was goodness
she's a phenomenal performer in the film
which we all knew she was but it's still
great to see on film Sam Elliot is great
Sam Elliott's always incredible it looks
great Matthew Lee batik the
cinematographer I've pardon me I've
dropped this factoid before but Matthew
Lee batik the DP of this movie had two
films open on the same weekend this
movie and Venom really and they opened
against each other interesting yes
a star is born yeah there you go
you know yeah a fantastic cast and then
it just starts to unravel let now let's
jump let's jump into the weirdness a
little bit
you've got the weird manager that takes
her on a really bizarre arc music man we
say this in the trailer the managers and
music movies are never good news and
British music managers are worse news
yes absolutely
so just no good it's no weird horrible
snake people yeah yeah it kind of falls
off the deep end his uh his arc is
really bizarre he cleans up and then
someone's like I'm gonna say one mean
sentence to you and then he's gone yeah
yeah just felt a little I felt like they
they knew where their marks were and
they had to scurry to get there at the
last third of the movie but yeah that
does not discount all the good things
about it yeah no I absolutely agree we
did this because there's usually one
sort of oscar movie that we feel like
has two breakout potential and this is
the one that we decided to do yeah we
could have done Bohemian Rhapsody maybe
but I'm I'm getting bored yelling about
it yeah and it's what are you gonna say
it's most of the Oscar movies if you
want to know what we would have said I
know a lot of people cuz green booked
one last night it was like oh you should
do an us do an Australia for green
booked everything we had to say about
Green Book was in the thirty second clip
that we did for the Aussie yeah pizza
box man yeah dubious real-life events
yeah
Dumb and Dumber diarrhea joke like maybe
the two of us doing the honest trailer
for Green Book is also the doubling down
on but that could be us feeding into why
so many people perhaps we're not happy
with green books I agree
I also wonder could we do believe or
what are you gonna claim that the music
would be I mean this one I'm worried
about cuz we did parody the music yeah
I'm afraid the good Gaga lawyers will be
after us well you and I feel like we're
missing a piece we have to spend he's
the the he's the motor he really is I
got it I gotta adjust
this show I apologize everybody oh it's
not on you it is at all though is this
from director Bradley Cooper comes the
fourth version of the same story that
was such a huge hit we're all gonna have
to watch Logan Paul and Northwest do it
again in 20 years
pause Haas no I was not in the room for
this why exactly did you move away from
originally was Logan Paul and Suri
Cruise so yeah we're like a whole bunch
of child celebrities in the room and I
think at the end
Spencer remembered the name Northwest
and was like that's the funniest name
that Reuben so went with that I I think
yeah Logan Paul and Sarah Cruz would
have been a good one I was going the
other way where I was trying to replace
Logan Paul mm-hmm with actors and
personalities that are currently about
his age and my the problem with those
was then everyone was like I watched
that in 20 years so yeah Logan Paul had
to remain the constant which is the
saddest thing I've ever said that's the
most insane sentence I've ever heard
yeah so yeah it started as sory it went
it went through a couple of went through
a couple of kids and yeah until we
landed on Northwest I hope in 30 years
somebody's sitting and probably these
exact chairs mm-hmm because they can't
be replaced apparently mistype the fact
that they all sink and they're like
let's go in the wayback machine they
predicted this in second yeah 2019 Oh
Jane Smith was who I was
proponent placing Logan Paul Weston okay
I can see both let's go JT a star is
born
leave Jackson Maine a musician who looks
like he smells like Rocket Raccoon who's
so whiskey-soaked he can go toe-to-toe
with Sam Elliott and a growl off duty
promising any as long as ever watch him
cry pause the more I watch footage from
a stars born I've watched the movie
twice now I go back and I remember
reading an interview with Tom Hanks
where the whole character of Forrest
Gump came because he matched the kid
that played young forest yes he recorded
the kid and then he matched he he
tailored his own voice yes and the
weirdness of portraying Forrest Gump
beside the match is interesting to me
and the more I watch Bradley Cooper the
more I'm like man he didn't just try to
growl like Sam Elliott like a lot of his
mannerisms are similar a lot of the way
he liked Cox's head you know cuz Sam
Elliott has that kind of like he always
called Sherlock there's for sure and
like Bradley Cooper keeps pulling those
little Sam Ellie it takes and I just
think it's really impressive yeah Sam
Ellie I really should get 70% of the
credit for the I don't know if you know
this but he also did Lady Gaga's vocals
not many people know that I love Sam
Elliott so so much I David pac-man or
social media guy made the mistake of
sending me our Twitter login during the
Oscars so I was tweeting during our
Oscars on the screen junkies main
account so I you know tweeted something
about the this is Sam Ellie it's Oscar
win for Roadhouse and you know a bunch I
love that dude we had our anniversary
lunch a couple years ago my wife and I
at this little place in Malibu and it
was completely empty except for Sam
Elliott and Sam Elliott's wife and they
were sitting behind us and I was like
freaking out and we just quietly sat and
listened to Sam Elliott go through the
menu with the waitress and it was like
the best thing I've ever walked through
Thermidor they'll up how about this
pumpkin spice for a vo because the the
best combination of words I've ever
heard of such an amazing gift to the
world
was I'm so excited to see this weird
Bigfoot movie he made yes
let's go let's watch watch him combine
the thrill of being a rockstar with the
frustration of hanging out with your
grandpa who refuses to put his hearing
aids in there you haven't been drinking
what do you say sorry what's working for
Willy
I've been working for Willy but he still
got the looks of Bradley Cooper plus the
talent of a Bradley Cooper musical side
project of an aging 30 odd photo
situation itself to a hot new talent is
the best one since Jeff Bridges did the
exact same thing in crazy heart which is
basically the story of a star is born
you wrote that ten people give 10 years
of their life to be able to do something
like that and it just pours out of you
know just fell out of me I guess none of
this page I'm bad I'm gonna have to haul
it I'm Jack I'm but I'll call it it's
like a ripoff of a ripoff that's also a
remake of a remake of a remake it's the
same story told over and over nailed it
cause every that we take our headphones
off because there's a delight in case
you're wondering we can hear infinity
Dan that's an honest trailer commentary
commentary we're just not it's not just
that we're weird yeah that was my one
and not that not that Bradley Cooper was
he was very good in the movie but I I
don't know if you've seen crazy heart I
saw crazy heart is very good Jeff
Bridges won Best Actor for it about ten
years ago but it's it's it's it's
strikingly similar the character is
strikingly similar art and and many of
the mannerisms are also strikingly
similar and there are there a thematic
apparently you have Sam Elliott well
they know each other from Big Lebowski
so maybe and maybe he just hung around
and was sitting in that bowling alley
and taking mental notes for if he ever
played a drunk cowboy which he ended up
doing but yeah and that was one thing
was you know when people like Bradley
Cooper's great he was was too and we the
same thing
no not that brett bradley cooper didn't
steal anything it's just funny how the
same kinds of roles recur and how they
often attract we have attention we have
an Americano thirst for a grizzled
mm-hmm
country no-nonsense sad old drunk cowboy
that's right who's just as americana as
the decor at an Applebee's yeah and yeah
we just can't get enough man no we can't
so yeah if you have a scene crazy hard
by the way check it out I can't wait
until these guys remake the mule never
the mule is a is a perfect absurdist
masterpiece on its own it's a realism at
its finest it will live on its own
forever yeah let's go jte they will
change when he meets Ali a woman who's
tragically burdened with a job that
expects her to be on time this was
strange because she's at her job in like
the first of the second time that
they're also like she's like hey it's
your turn take out the trash and she's
like it's your job and then like they
get she quits because he says hey you're
late and she's like I'm out of here
this job sucks it's like yeah like they
treated it not like I get the idea of
like oh she finally is able to quit this
this job she doesn't I get that but the
idea that like they treat him and the
movie kind of wants us to think that the
boss is like some a-hole bottom [ __ ]
yeah there's just a guy who's frustrated
that two of his employees are apparently
constantly late for work I would be
upset by this too if the movie was about
him he'd be a very sympathetic
protagonist would be he would be the Jon
Favreau and chef of this movie he
probably quit to go start his own food
truck in the universe that this film
exists in I like that a lot of truck is
born I'll watch that movie yeah there's
some weird characterization things in
this movie
where I felt like it was asking you to
side with certain characters when
because you're expected to yes you know
the trope this is one where they have
like a big fight and you know like it's
the big he's drunk and and she's famous
and fight and they one of them starts it
but like she gets personal first she
could sue personal yeah she's a console
personal and then he gets personal and
they both say terrible things to each
other and then the movie has the scene
where they get back together and he's
like hey I'm really sorry and she's like
what you said really hurt me and he's
like yeah I'm really sorry and I'm like
that's great that he did that but then
the movie never loose back to
acknowledge the fact like wait a minute
she she started it cuz she said some
really messed up stuff when you verbally
held him by the head and kneed him in
the skull over don't
yes he got personal but you went you
went to the drunk dad thing for us
collided this fire but the movie sort of
wants you to sympathize only it seemed
like only with one side of it and and
that was another where it's just like I
I'm kind of the boss the side of here
yeah you were late you were late and you
drunk at it that was rough yeah so I
don't know I maybe that's just me I
think that's a good way of talking about
though the movie short hands a lot in
places that it's not really interested
in investing time yeah because you know
how the story works once we know what
we're getting and in the end be an extra
step to let's just breeze through this
yeah exactly exactly fix the second man
slightly larger nose then your average
pop star I guess and the dice man for a
dad was an old lady lived in a shoe she
has so many kids the uterus fell out Oh
comedy you got it'll kick off a romance
full of fighting screwing and an
unsettling amount of face touching
that's his eye and trying to get off
having this be a runner he I'll talk
about in a second did this this one goes
on three times as long though spiral is
a country song that I can't I'm sorry
that goes that goes on three times as
long in the movie with the basally or
whatever that is that cake or whatever
it's just like he does it so and then he
just like is rubbing it the the the the
thing of it is it's the precursor to an
argument mm-hmm and he's not kind of the
fracture point of their relationship
he's being like really aggressive she
kind of acknowledges it she badass but
in a like oh you suck but yeah and the
movie sort of plays it off as like oh
these two based on what I am told about
him by the movie I'll jump into it now
because I was going to talk about sort
of in the last section
Jackson's character makes me really
uncomfortable
as a person who has had very like
intense controlling people in his life
before like the moment Jackson comes in
with this larger-than-life like cannot
touch face can I touch your eyebrows do
you want to fly to this thing for me I'm
gonna have someone follow you around
until you fly to this thing with me get
on stage you don't say get on stage get
on stage you don't you won't get married
we're getting married we're getting
married now like I'm gonna put a bagel
in your face if you make me mad the
weird one is when he Edward from
Twilight it into her bedroom like yes go
back to sleep and kick him out it's not
worth it and you know I on one hand I
think the movie was trying to say like
both of these people are really screwed
up and this is their screwed-up
relationship but it sort of saddled the
line between that and isn't this
beautiful romance and it's not it was it
ended a beautiful romance it is done
this was a beautiful romance but yeah it
was like
we're terrible for each other but it was
a beautiful romance which is it is what
it is yeah just watch the whole movie
watching him I was like I hate him so
much
really yeah he's like you're gifts you
know like yeah yeah it's weird there's
like going on with his character right
earth then lets her manager turn her
into JLo crossed with Lila from the pit
element for some reason then Jackson
lets the same manager talk him into
killing himself for some reason just by
staying merits you she looks like a joke
it's embarrassing man as a music manager
ever been a good guy in any movie can't
trust him okay positive oh wait yeah
let's talk man it's my biggest problem
with the movie is it felt like we took
the chutes and ladders shortcut to the
end there with the concept that through
through one conversation and then sort
of the the movie thing of not talking to
each other he would take that such a
dramatic step yeah and I you know I know
some people don't have a problem with it
but for me it felt a bit a bit like a
shortcut like we've got a we've got to
get him to we spent a lot of time at the
beginning because we love these two
characters yeah but it's two hours into
the movie and we we've got to kind of
get to the end so it's sort of
fast-forward a bit there is plenty of
truth that someone who is as troubled
and has as many demons it just takes a
bad moment
it really takes just a bad moment but
the movie doesn't play like that the
movie plays it like that weird
conversation with the manager the light
bulb went off and yeah like a light goes
off he's like I got to go I got to go do
this where I think something much more
honest would have just been something
triggers on his own I think that's
really for me and everyone interprets it
differently but my interpretation of it
I think it would have been more
if you had seen them have actual instead
of this guy saying like you're gonna be
tempted and you're gonna give him like
to see even if there was a beat of him
having that actual temptation yes show
don't tell you know because he does he
does take the the bottle like but he's
already sort of made up his mind at that
point yeah at the idea of this just that
one extra step of him realizing like
he's right and I don't like this I don't
want to believe him but he's absolutely
right it just felt like there's a step
missing somewhere we went from like a
tea to see and we didn't stop yeah I
think the things at the man yeah it's
okay you know it's a shortcut scene
because I think if we had seen the
things that the manager described you
get there in a much sadder more real way
because not only is he a recovering
addict dealing with depression and a
million other things he's now completely
he doesn't even have the the fame the
structure of Fame no to keep him going
so I think you could have gotten there
in an organic way because now he's on
his own she's off you know doing god
knows what their roles have been
completely reversed yeah he doesn't have
that control he doesn't have that
structure anymore and that's that's
dangerous I heard something like that I
don't usually advocate for movies to be
longer however I feel like this if this
movie was like five minutes longer it
might have actually helped it yeah I
wish that they had trusted themselves to
see the story through take an extra
because they sort of have the scene
where she comes in and says I'm
canceling my tour and that's supposed to
be a little connective piece between the
two but I just felt like they could have
really put a solid hinge on that yeah
that's one man's opinion well I know but
they're movie stars and I'm some yokel
sitting on and let's talk about the
manager too and his managers are always
been his weird career choices for Ally
because I've never I've never seen in
the history of watching music or
breakout stars
you know someone gets famous on their
own doing a thing that they do and then
a manager coming in and and being like
perfect let's not do that ever again
you you see it with people where it's
not working like Katy Perry I think was
trying to be like a Christian artist for
a while I think I'm not an X ray Creed
who definitely was yeah and someone came
in and was like that's not working put
whipped cream cones on your boobs and
that we ran and it worked and for creed
they were like let's let's take a few
Gospels out of your leg said and it
worked did but I've never seen it the
other way around where someone is just
like this homerun hit like no one was
like hey Justin Bieber stop doing pop
songs right is it be a country artist no
yeah yeah add some fake twang and and
we're gonna black Croce up yeah that
didn't happen it was a definite from a
sort of pop country vibe to be like and
now you are a knockoff of a second-rate
Katy Perry yeah like that's Taylor Swift
just make her an older Taylor Swift if
that's what you're going well that's
part of the thing is did that argument
that they had when he's just like you're
know this was harsh when he said you're
an embarrassment and he's like I'm what
it's just like what are you doing you're
but song or whatever you're off it's a
terrible song I'm actually glad that
they had I love that they actually wrote
a terrible song for the movie it
would've been easier to write an actual
like in my opinion so he was a terrible
song to write an actually good pop song
for the movie I love that the song they
wrote for the movie was beautiful and
terrible I love that they they got that
and we're just gonna write another great
soundtrack song apologies to anyone who
likes the pop song for this it's
terrible but that's that's another part
where it's like he was coming from a
germ of trying to push her to be like
what are you doing but it's mmm
it was all those two that's when he's
too broken to do it it's too broken and
had a couple too many yeah were two
broken people yeah but yeah the the Lilu
transformation is is odd that guy should
be fired
yes he doesn't seem like the best
manager and yet Ali still got famous
yeah sure what do we know Dan what do we
know we don't know anything about making
a fictional character no no nothing so
it swept away by this grand tale of love
or at least a grand tale of an alcoholic
who used a girl to feel something again
and the girl who used an alcoholic as a
stepping stone to fame ah in a story
that really drives home the destructive
power of having the same two songs from
the soundtrack stuck in your head so we
had to do songs the two trailer songs
are the two that we had to do yeah it'd
be weird if we tried not to yeah you
gotta so I'm excited this turned out
well
it was almost gone it stopped maybe it's
time to let the remix
good old Matt citroën thank you as
always
fluor remakes is a lot to take killers
made my graph mile try maybe it's time
to let the remix day
[Music]
[Applause]
can I just say how excited I lost we got
to write a parody song with the line yes
so that was I have to give her a little
bit of love that was a my friend Ruby
Lewis oh who I went to college with who
is one of the best singers I've ever
heard in my life she was the lead and
the play paramour on Broadway recently
she's doing a Marilyn Monroe musical in
Vegas right now
she she's done all of those in Hollywood
they're those little like evening with
blank director and they do little
musical versions she's in all of those I
was like an evening with Quentin
Tarantino and you know all that stuff
and she's awesome look her up on YouTube
there's a lot of really cool videos of
her singing she does a you know Jeff
Goldblum jazz band plays regularly here
she did an amazing duet with Jeff
Goldblum and I don't think it's actually
a really cool video I don't think Jeff
Goldblum never had ever heard her sing
they were just like Ruby's gonna sing
with you anyway okay great and the
moment he just starts like belting like
Jeff Goldblum space just goes and he
just gets so excited and just starts
playing like harder so I was she knocked
this out of the park I don't know what
she'd be able to do this British music
yeah maybe too talented a person for any
dumb jokes I've ever written to be put
to subscribe me we did make her again
signal and eat it we wrote that because
we knew that it we knew that this would
be out the day after the Oscars yeah and
we knew that because it's music we
didn't have a whole lot of flexibility
with it so we I know that as we were
doing the lyrics we tried to make it so
that by saying give me my Oscar now that
worked for if either or if Lady Gaga won
the Best Actress if Bradley Cooper won
Best Actor if both of them won neither
but we were almost positive that it was
gonna win best song so yeah we knew that
we could put a shot of Lady Gaga most
likely with an Oscar somewhere in that
yeah and then we didn't know that they
were so smart we didn't have the but
to have them sing two versions of this
we did not know that they were going to
make spiritual love to each other on the
awesome world to see where it's a happy
accident that was very intense and I
know a lot of people have have actually
been surprised about this a lot of
people coming at us pretty hard for
making that they're definitely doing it
joke like guys I do why can't two people
and it's like I know that two people can
do it they but it's also just fun to say
that they did it yeah although if
they're not then they both should have
won that Oscar yes yeah yeah all right
they should have won an adult II is that
what the porn Awards are called I have
no idea I mean either I can't remember
let's go all we hear is Lady yo Gaga Joe
is rocking raccoon what are you doing in
this movies you know hanging with mr.
Cooper just wanted to make another meme
of you and Sam Elliott saying the f-word
that's half his dialogue yeah it's
amazing
boring start premise he's like the way
his mouth moves when he says the f-word
yeah it's like he ate something yeah
tart for tomorrow simile it's the dude
I'm sorry about that DG name one other
actor that can cry and drove a truck
backwards so worried I heard wife's in
the theaters like that's the best acting
in the movie yeah he used my favorite
performance in that movie he saw
everybody yeah he's so good he's awesome
in it he is I I realized I didn't
realize I was Andrew Dice Clay until
Spencer told me it was really didn't
know this man did not register with me
at all that that was a dice man I'll
tell you what I didn't realize it was
Chappelle until they were getting
married I don't know why I spent the
whole time just later bad guys familiar
wait that whole scene where they're
standing outside talking on the porch
yeah dude where it's Bradley Cooper
obviously talking to Dave Chappelle yeah
you didn't know that was Dave so you
have no idea how I did that because then
I was watching the wedding and I was
like wait is that Chappelle
then I went back to the first scene and
I was like how did I not know that was
Chappell oh you know very shoddily could
not know that that was that was he was
being I was just being Dave Chappelle I
was just lost in the story of a star is
born dan I don't I don't see actors at
that point I just see the characters
there yeah I'll say yeah I had no idea I
don't know what I don't think my brain
okay I don't think my brain allowed me
to register the idea that Dave Chappelle
was randomly in a star is born
okay well that may be like because he's
weird that's got some that bears a
little bit of cream sing but that also
ties into Jackson being a weirdly
controlling character cuz I feel like
everyone's story about being in this
movie wasn't because Bradley Cooper
harassed them until they said they'd do
it okay cuz Chappelle was like fine and
I think Gaga was like fine and Elliott
was like fine after just months and
months and months same with the dice man
I don't know why he was like you have to
do this well I'm come on your dice of
course you said he is it's gonna be an
oscar movie yes you're gonna be in it I
think TT sub Lee telling us to hurry up
I'm sorry starring Lady Antebellum
deserves the Oscar for this shot alone
[Music]
Bradley Kaka loyal extremely hazardous
you know I like this movie but the
version starring Beyonce directed by
Clint Eastwood would have been something
that mule exists I can weirdly now that
the mule exists I can see that that that
movie was almost a thing because I can
see Clint Eastwood being someone being
like Clint do you want to maybe play the
Haggard older brother he's like no I'm
Jackson main yeah I'm Jackson man he
takes me I'm a bull of the rock star
taking this young woman under my wing
the star that's born is this chair now
let's go have some threesomes yes okay
it would be the mule except it's just
would be called a star is born yeah yeah
that would that would have been that
would have been something I've been a
whole thing Joe that's the stars
it is that's our first Spenser las'
commentary listen boy it'll be more than
just the two of us lon wasn't feeling
well he had to go home a little sick was
it with this and then we're we're gonna
we're bringing in some some favorites
yeah to help us out so hopefully they
can come and join us in the commentaries
as well but yeah Spencer congratulations
again buddy we are so so happy for you
I hope that kid gets to work and starts
doing some chores and starts being
useful soon yeah because you guys have
been working really hard Congrats again
and let's tease next week's next week's
trailer oh I'm excited about next week's
trailer it was one of the worst movies
of 2018 and I was the personal champion
for us to do this movie are you saying
that this movie didn't quite hit the
mark it didn't it may have missed the
mark yes it's good now I think that's
good yeah have you figured out bye guys
we'll see you next week
[Music]
you